admit it your phone or computers
address-book
looks a little like this hi I'm Joanna
and this entry has my cell phone number
hi I'm Joanna and this entry has my
email address hi
me again this entry has my work email
address from ten years ago yeah it's a
total mess in here
and most of us just let all the junk
collect because who actually has time to
deal with editing and deleting
information for thousands of contacts
but now with so many apps and devices
like the Apple watch talking to our
address book it's more important than
ever that we tidy up this place and I
promise it doesn't have to be so hard
you just have to follow my contact
cleanup plan okay you won't really need
these the first thing you can do is what
I call a quick cleanup this just tidies
up your phone's address book on the
iPhone you can manually merge contacts
while you slowly develop carpal tunnel
instead use a free app called cleanup
duplicate contacts of all the contact
cleaning apps I tried this was the best
you review its work and decide what to
merge on most Android phones it's a
similar situation you can go contact by
contact but you're better off using
merge plus a free app that will do that
for you
Samsung actually included a mass merging
feature on the Galaxy s6 which is very
helpful if all you're looking to do is
clean up your phone's contact lists then
you can stop watching this video right
now but that basic approach won't get to
the root of the problem my deep cleanse
however lets you create one single
address book that thinks across all your
devices the first step is to pick a
storage service where all these contacts
will live
I chose Google you then want to export
all the other address books you have and
import them into that service once you
have everything in one place it's time
to use scrub li to clean up the service
is free if you have less than 250
contacts but it costs $20 for a one-time
clean of your massive address book once
I logged in with my Google account it
analysed all my contacts then prompted
me to merge duplicates and delete
unimportant people it even reformatted
all my phone numbers
it also allows you to log into social
media accounts like Twitter Facebook and
LinkedIn to get more information about
your contacts then with just one click
it saved all that information to my
Google account going forward I've set up
my iPhone so that when I input a new
contact it's only saved to my Google
address book
no more iCloud or other services it's me
again with all my contact information in
one single entry no more evil clones
either now keep it clean